Hey Youtubers its Charlie
so today we are going to talk about gorilla grodd
because Andrew kriesberg, on of the executives producers of the flash show tweeted this message in honor of geoff johns birthday last week
it almost went unnoticed because he doesn't have a lot of followers
but its a really big deal
if you've never had the chance to meet geoff johns hes just one of the famous flash comic book writers
and hes very involved in the tv show when ever hes not off writing other comic books or advising on the dc movies
hes the chief creative at dc, he does like everything that they do,
movies, tv shows, comics
this video is mostly going to be a history of grodd in the comics, but i will
talk about how i think the show is going to use him